foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
John Murphy he's been calling the bills
action radio play-by-play for 19 Seasons
now we thought we'd check in with John
to Gage what's in store coming up this
weekend John what are the uh plans for
the game and is there a plan B right now
yeah
there is a plan B but it's not public
right now but yeah the plans are one
o'clock kickoff on Sunday I just
listened to a pretty respected weather
forecaster here who said by Sunday it'll
be over there won't be any new snow on
Sunday it'll be sunny actually on Sunday
but it's of course uh the lead up to
Sunday including uh you know starting
tonight at seven o'clock until maybe
tomorrow evening seven o'clock Thursday
night into Friday where there could be
as much as two to four feet of snow so
we'll see what would be Plan B in your
opinion well I mean they have eight
years ago the move to Detroit right and
that's been talked about a lot it was a
pretty successful move uh actually it
was right around this time of year in
2014 there was a bad November snowstorm
and uh the difference is that occurred
on a Tuesday and the bills got out of
here a little bit earlier than they
would uh at this point but they would go
to Detroit and play that game the lions
are out of town and so they would play
at Ford Field uh probably one o'clock on
Sunday uh the bills would lose that home
game and actually the Bills play
Thanksgiving Day in Detroit also you
know four days later so maybe they stay
I don't know but I haven't been uh
apprised of what their plan is and they
they're a million scenarios as to what
could happen right now they're still
planning on playing one o'clock on
Sunday but we'll see you think the bills
want to play whatever it takes to be
able to play this game at home instead
of we can play you know a neutral site
and play in you know uh sterile
conditions there in Detroit
yeah I think they'd rather play at home
just because at this point it would be a
pretty major disruption of the routine
right I mean the practice yesterday uh
practice scheduled today they have an
indoor practice facility the same on
Friday to pick up everything and move it
would uh I think entail a lot of uh up
people and I don't think they're up for
that uh as I said the forecast is for
sunny skies and they're used to playing
in the cold so I don't think they're
afraid to play in wintry conditions
Sunday even if it is sunny it'll be
chilly and maybe a little Breezy but
yeah I'm sure their preferences to stay
home to play at home and not pick up the
whole operation not not even uh
considering the amount of Revenue they
could lose if they have to forego a uh a
home game you know that's a lot of money
down the drain they wouldn't they
wouldn't have what's the Fallout bin
from the loss to the Vikings oh it's not
good but I think they're in good shape I
mean it's weird it's a weird fan base
that uh almost expects the bills to go
to the Super Bowl now and I think and
you've been around a long time like I
haven't you think nobody and should have
an expectation to go into the Super Bowl
the league is so competitive and it's so
uh evenly matched that uh they have an
expectation to go to the Super Bowl I
think is unrealistic however you know
the bills have lost just three uh last
Sunday losing to Minnesota was a tough
one Minnesota is a pretty good team and
they lost it overtime on a play that on
a game that had maybe four or five plays
that if either any of them had gone the
other way then the bills would have won
I mean they they were evenly matched if
not slightly better than Minnesota so I
think they they need to get back on
track you know they need to start this
week against a a decent Cleveland team
will be ready to go and they have their
backs up against the wall but I think
the bills clearly have more even with
the injuries the bills have they have
more uh Talent than the Cleveland Browns
but they've got to play like it and and
the big question of course is Josh Allen
right I mean he's got to play better
he's had a rough a couple of weeks maybe
two and a half weeks and I think uh I
don't think it's a physical question as
much as it is right now I think he's
pressing too much he knows all the
injuries they've had defensively and
he's probably pressing too much trying
to make up for some of the injuries
they've had and and uh it's come back to
haunt him with all the uh Red Zone
interception for them in the last two
weeks where do we stand on a new stadium
for buffalo
uh the shovel should go on the ground
next Spring right across the street from
uh Highmark Stadium
um it'll be a little smaller Stadium
it'll be open air with a covered canopy
over most of the seating but uh the plan
is to get the construction started next
spring
um they've got a few other loose ends to
tie it before that actually happens but
I think they're on target to have that
done but open air they're they're gonna
still invite the elements in there yeah
yeah I mean you know a a dome was kind
of cost prohibitive and to be honest I
was thinking about this today this is
the 49th year of the stadium here in
Orchard Park and uh so far there's only
been one game forced in those 49 years
one game forced to move so there's you
know the fans can kind of uh put up with
it they they will have more covered
seating to get them out of the rain and
sometimes the cold rain and the snow
that will fall but yeah it's going to be
open air uh especially over the field
it'll be totally open air good luck this
weekend John we appreciate your time my
pleasure thanks Dan that's John Murphy
he's been calling a uh bills
play-by-play on radio for uh 19 seasons